Today we're so
interested in the study
of how some of these
extreme climate
events that we've
been seeing, how
they affect human societies.
You know, how dop they
affect them over a long term?
How do they affect them over
a wide geographic region?
How does the same
climate event play out
in lots of different
parts of the planet?
Well, today, of
course, we can watch
that evolve when an event hits.
But what happened in the past?
Tree rings provide this
incredible way to do that.
Because they're
these kind of passive
sentinels recording time
and lots of other things
to go with that time.
So in each time capsule
that's locked away
in a tree ring sequence, we
have all kinds of information.
We have the radiocarbon that was
in the environment at the time
that tree ring formed.
We have maybe oxygen isotopes,
maybe other carbon isotopes
that tell us about
rainfall, that might tell us
about temperature.
We can know that a tree is
putting on a ring every year.
And the amazing thing is
that if we start with today,
if you or I, if we
went outside and we
took a sample from under
the bark of any of the trees
that we see outside, we
would find a ring forming.
And it would be
this year's ring.
So we know the date.
And so we know the date of
the one before and the one
before and the one before
and the one before.
And the neat thing is
about tree ring research
is we can overlap these
patterns back 12,000 years
dated from today
all the way back,
each year represented
by a single ring.
So that's an amazing
way to measure time.
And it's an amazing archive.
And all the time
we're finding new ways
to unlock the secrets
of the tree rings.